interns interns it's not it's not what
you're going to learn this summer is not
in fact 94% of you are going to take
jobs where they're going to teach you
dumb ass [ __ ]
or stuff that you already know they're
mailing in their internships interns
it's not about what you're going to
learn to summer my friends it's going to
be who you meet please understand as you
go into this internship maximize
networking shake hands kiss babies if
you're a Wallflower don't even do
internships like like not the classic
way like like obviously have a skill to
learn you're lucky enough to be a
developer or something like that but
fine but like if you're an intern please
understand it is the human connections
that you're going to make way too many
people roll in and think they're going
to learn something about advertising or
marketing or media or startups you're
not you're just not here you're not just
saving you time and if you do it's just
this much it's 3% of the equation please
attack the other 97 go to every
after-hours event
say hello to every
buddy if you go into an office where
everybody's head down it's not that kind
of culture figure it out hack it be the
obnoxious intern that was too bubbling
and make sure you attach yourself even
if you go into an office law firm where
everybody's head down if you see that
one person that looks up and gives you a
glimmer of people skills attach yourself
to that person let them bring you two
things
interns use this time wisely way too
many of you go in and you think you're
going to get something and in reality
the magic was sitting right in front of
you and the punchline my friends is it's
the people it's the people it's the
people that you meet in that office that
go work somewhere else that are reminded
by your hustle and tenacity and good
nature 'no sand offense and you went for
it you attached for it you want it in
and and they're the ones that give you
the opportunities this is a very simple
world this is a people world
not the black and white skills learned
this summer in eight weeks half of you
are going to get coffee and do dumb [ __ ]
because they disrespect the youth and
appropriately so please even if you are
in that 50 percent that's getting dumped
[ __ ] coffees and things that's
nature say hello
you drop a coffee off to somebody and
they've got a Cardinals pennant and you
know something about the Cardinals say
something say something about Adam
Wainwright create relationships it is
the only KPI it is the only ROI of an
internship
you